collègues ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre à nyon massivement augmenté les
impôts depuis juillet 2012
sans ligne directrice vous avez fait
naître un sentiment d'incompréhension
voire de refus de l'impôt notre économie
et nos concitoyens souffrent aujourd'hui
de ces hausses d'impôts de ce matraquage
fiscal qui devrait concerner que les
riches qui concerne tout le monde et
particulièrement les classes moyennes et
puis tout le monde souffrent de ces
mesures économiques contradictoires que
vous prenez alors elles annonçant sans
préparation
une remise à plat de la fiscalité vous
ne fait qu'aggraver la confusion et
accroître les risques d'effets très
négatif sur notre économie
du fait de l'instabilité que vous créez
et que présage les acteurs économiques
monsieur le premier ministre n'est t'il
pas tant d'avoir système fiscal qui soit
lisible cohérent
s'inscrivant dans la durée et coordonnée
à ceux de nos partenaires européens
parce que notre économie a besoin avant
tout de stabilité et de confiance
nous voudrions savoir monsieur le
premier ministre
quelle est votre méthode quel est le
calendrier de la réforme
quelle est la logique d'ensemble et pour
quels impôts parce que la fiscalité
locale parait-il serait-elle tel serait
traitée ultérieurement à 10 ans dit on
pourquoi la fiscalité aussi
environnemental est elle traitée à part
où on pas traiter du tout je pense
d'ailleurs à l'écotaxe par exemple alors
monsieur le premier ministre nous
regrettons d'ores et déjà que vous ne
placier pas cette réforme au service de
la compétitivité de nos entreprises qui
sont seules sources de création
d'emplois durables nous regrettons que
nous placier pas tout ça sous le signe
de la nécessaire réduction de la dépense
publique
et puis moi je vous le dit la seule
réforme fiscale aujourd'hui qui est
possible c'est la réduction de nos
impôts merci la parole à monsieur pierre
moscovici ministre de l'économie et des
finances monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice marie-hélène des esgaulx
je vous remercie de votre question comme
toujours marqué de la bonhomie de la
lucidité et décide d'encouragement que
vous nous avez prodigués du grand
équilibre de votre position qui me
touche toujours profondément je n'aurai
pas la cruauté de vous rappeler la
situation dans laquelle se trouvait la
france en 2012
mais je pourrais le faire pendant cinq
ans car c'est bien de ça dont il s'agit
il s'agit du redressement des finances
publiques du pays que vous avez laissé
avec un déficit qui était supérieure à
5% du pib
il s'agit du désendettement progressif
du pays car vous avez accumulé 600
milliards de dette publique
en plus il s'agit du redressement de la
compétitivité du pays
car franchement quand vous évoquez ce
mot on se passe temps vous avez laissé
se dégrader
cette compétitivité et je n'aurai pas la
cruauté de vous rappelez vous même les
mesures fiscales que vous avez prises
d'abord le paquet fiscal qui a creusé
les déficits
puis ensuite les hausses d'impôts plus
de 1% par an en 2010 2011 est en effet
2012 et donc si vous voulez jeu parfois
je me dis que plutôt que de faire ce
genre de péroraisons vous devriez vous
excuser auprès des français alors cela
étant dit je veux nous expliquer ce que
le premier ministre entend faire car
c'est précisément une remise à plat de
notre système fiscal afin que celui ci
soit plus simple afin que celui ci soit
plus lisible afin qu'il y ait de la
stabilité qui en émergent et afin qu'il
y ait plus de justice dans ce système
fiscal et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous allons nous attaquer à la fois à la
fiscalité des entreprises avec la
volonté de préserver et d'améliorer la
compétitivité à la fiscalité des ménages
avec le sou
de la simplifier et de la rendre plus
juste et au financement de la protection
sociale afin que celui ci soit à la fois
pérenniser qu'ils demeurent appropriés
par les partenaires sociaux et qu'il
crée de la justice voilà ce que nous
voulons faire et vous le savez d'autant
plus que le premier ministre a souhaité
recevoir les groupes tous les groupes
parlementaires et qu'il a offert au
groupe à tous les groupes de s'associer
à ce travail travail qui doit trouver de
premières concrétisations dans le projet
de loi finances pour 2015 mais qui en
effet prendra plus de temps que cela
tant cette remise à plat est une oeuvre
de longue haleine et donc n'essayez pas
de faire peur aux français
au contraire nous voulons la une
fiscalité plus stable plus simple plus
juste plus lisible c'est cela que nous
voulons faire c'est le redressement
d'une situation que vous avez dégradée
et les français le savent
merci ce gilbert ranger pour le groupe
socialiste